[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on Tristan J George how are y'all
doing we're doing great how are you I
was a the wisest redneck I know says
better than I
deserve I'm glad Dave's not here to hear
that the he might take wisest redneck
that's
nice yeah yeah hey hey I'm I'm a
descendant of many a redneck so I I'm
right there there you go there you go I
love it how can help today yeah so I'm
uh in baby step two right now I've got
I've got about $40,000 worth of debt
that's mostly student loans and then a
yeah then a I've got a car loan that uh
I well I was recently driving around a
brand new car but I listened to Dave and
sold that and got a cheaper car for the
time being that I just owe about five
grand on now okay great and yeah and so
ah the only credit card that I have is
One credit card that uh I've really
discovered about a year ago on Father's
Day when my mom kind of unexpectedly
passed away oh man and yeah and when me
and my uh me and my siblings were
helping my dad go sorry go through
everything and kind of get uh try to get
him sorted out because we knew our mom
handled most of the finances uh we
actually had discovered that she had
opened up I think it was 12 credit cards
in his name and 11 in my name yeah oh my
goodness 11 cards in your name hey I'm
sorry that's tough I mean it's tough
enough you lost your mom and then to
discover a secret like that that's
painful yeah yeah it it was it was rough
for a little while but thankfully I've
got a uh at the time I had a wonderful
girlfriend who helped me get through it
and now she's my fiance okay that we're
gonna get married soon um but my my main
question is that uh 10 of the cards I
showed them uh some information reported
a claim to them saying that these are
fraudulent and they like were actually
really helpful immediately closed them
out reported them as fraudulent okay and
there's just one card that initially
told me that oh yeah we're going to
close this out in about a week and then
I found out a few months later that they
were uh they had in fact not closed the
card out and they had been charging me
late fees and it just been yeah did you
get it in writing that they were going
to close it unfortunately no it was all
over the phone yeah and basically we've
been going back and forth for about a
year and it turns out the thing that
they are hanging on right now to keep it
open is that when I was 18 uh my mom had
bought me a plane ticket to go visit my
older brother in California as like an
early birthday present okay and she
apparently had done that on that credit
card so there was a plane ticket in my
name so so like hey this isn't fraud
what's what's the balance on it what's
the balance on the card it was about
1,800 but after the late fees now it's
like 2,200 and so part part of me is
just kind of frustrated and just and
just kind of want to be like okay let me
maybe just throw this in the debt
snowball but the other part of me is
just like d n I'm not I don't want to
let this freaking credit card company
win so what's your
income uh this year it's going to be
91 okay if I'm you this has been a year
of headache and hassle you lost your mom
this is not what you want consuming your
mental space yeah you know what I mean
and it's like if I don't want to
overstep but the longer that you have to
deal with this I feel like it has the
ability to kind of infiltrate what
you're feeling about your mom even like
she left me with this problem and now I
mean uh and it's just I feel like that
has that can be a really tangled web and
you can end up feeling like some
bitterness or like some anger towards
her when really all you want to do is
just grieve your
loss yeah and I I definitely felt that
for the for about the first six months
after she passed and yeah I went to went
to therapy for it Bill and so I I really
don't yeah that part I'm not really
holding on to anymore because she she
did what she did uh in her in her mind
she thought she was doing what was what
was the best for us and us other kids
but uh yeah so it it that I'm not too
worried about I'm just like yeah I I'm
still going to pay it George what would
you do I would call and say listen I'm
done with this here's what I'm asking
you to do just cut the late fees cut
this 400 bucks off I'm happy to pay the
original balance but we've been fighting
this thing I didn't even know about this
card and so I'll work with you on this
but I'm paying my 1,800 and that's it
and get that in writing and say hey I'm
closing the card after that so that's
what I would fight for but I wouldn't
fight to try to get it to zero over the
next 10 years like Jade said and just
it's too many brain calories yeah yeah
over too small of an amount of money
yeah I agree with that I I second that
notion George that's a
appreciate the call Tristan but that is
tough man you know I hear about this all
the time um and and this is not what
happened in Tristan's situation but for
moms and dads listening it is fraud if
you open up credit cards and the names
of your children like and say that it's
you that's fraud and not only that like
you have the ability to really Jack
their credit I know people personally
who this has been done to them and then
they hit 18 and they get into the world
and they're 21 and 23 and they're like
why do like why is my credit already bad
like what's happened to me and they find
out it's cuz their parents have opened
up cards their you mess with your kids
Financial life and the other Trend I'm
seeing Jade I'm seeing the all these
videos on Instagram and Tik Tok there's
all this advice saying hey add your kid
as an authorized user on your card even
if they're 3 years old when they're 18
they're going to have amazing credit and
they're going to be so grateful and
here's what happens the parents blow up
their kids credit Yeah by accident yes
and then screw up their kids's Financial
life before they're even an adult it's
so unfair it's so unfair you've got to
let your kids decide who they want to be
financially you don't don't just set
them out there and just assume that what
because what if they follow the Ramsay
way and they don't want to have anything
to do with credit and credit cards what
I could only hope I could only dream
that's the case George that's what we're
hoping for but um you've got to be
careful and then there's another
teaching in this George about um if you
are a monitoring Your Own Credit and
making sure you see all the accounts on
there because this guy is talking about
he said there were 10 accounts uh 11 in
his dad's name and then another 11
accounts in his name o yeah this is the
importance we are not for the credit
score but we are for pulling your credit
report once a year you can do this on
annual creditreport.com we have no
affiliation this is just the authorized
Federal website to do this for free and
that will show you every single trade
Line Credit account you have open every
single student loan everything it's
going to lay it all out to give you a
picture and that's how I found out that
fraud had happened to me yeah there was
an AT&T account and a Verizon account
opened across the country with a
previous address of mine in Nashville
wow that was opened and they added 1,700
bucks worth of debt wow onto both of
those accounts and the only way I found
that was pulling my credit report yeah
and getting a collector call saying hey
you owe us this money I went what I
didn't have Horizon yeah so there you go
something like that happened with samon
it was a Discover card and he was like I
don't know what this is I don't know
what it came from and yeah check your
credit CR score make sure you recognize
the debt and when you do pay it off